all right Senator J.D Vance he was with
the mayor and president Trump earlier
today he joins us now with more Senator
I've gotten to know you pretty well
you've been there now a number of times
one of the first times you went there
you took a video in that video you had
what looked like you know Moses's Rod a
big stick and you poke in the water and
when you just Stir the Water a little
bit up comes this I I don't even know
how to describe it what looked kind of
like an oil slick like I'm showing it
now there's something in that water
Senator that scares the hell out of me
and I would hate to think the people of
East Palestine will drink that
yeah Sean that's that's exactly right
here so first of all kudos to the mayor
and kudos to president Trump for
visiting today I think the mayor has
been a hero throughout this entire
situation uh so he's doing a great job
but but here's the thing that I worry
about Sean with the water with the air
you pointed it out exactly a lot of
people mistrust experts rightfully so
after the last couple of years when they
really screwed up the covet situation
when you still have poisonous soil in
East Palestine the cleanup is not yet
finished when you have people seeing
dead fish and dead you know crawdads in
their water they have every right to be
concerned about this and unfortunately
they don't think the government's
listening to them the by demonstration
they don't feel like Norfolk Southern is
listening to them and we've got to stay
on top of people to make sure that the
folks of East Palestine are not
forgotten that to me is the number one
job you heard the mayor say it the
safety of the residents is what we have
to care about not just tomorrow but over
the next couple of years and their own
government they don't feel like is
listening to them you know we have the
president over in Ukraine and Poland and
he pledged yet another half a billion
taxpayer dollars for Ukraine we've
already given close to 120 billion
taxpayer dollars uh but yet the
president has not been to East Palestine
uh tomorrow finally the transportation
secretary will show up there I wouldn't
expect he's going to get a very warm
reception uh are they a day late and a
dollar short or is there anything you
think they can do to make up for this
well look I I think so there's certainly
a day late and a dollar short but there
is a lot that they can do to make up for
this and to ensure that East Palestine
isn't forgotten into the future look
Sean the the the devastation in this
community you're going to have you know
some people staying but some people
trying to leave you're going to have
some businesses that have been destroyed
by this not through any fault of their
own not because they failed to sell a
good product but because of this
disaster and the effect that it's had on
the community so we're going to have to
take care of this community we're gonna
have to ensure uh that what happened at
the train crash almost three weeks ago
doesn't destroy this town and and like
the mayor said we're going to have to
stay on top of federal officials and
Norfolk Southern to make sure that
people are safe I think those are all of
the important things that we have to do
I'm certainly going to stay on top of it
I know a lot of people are as well if
they're going to give 120 billion
dollars to Ukraine you would think
they'd give enough money to make sure
the water is clean the air is clean and
it's safe for people to go back in their
homes in East Palestine I hope they get
that done Senator thank you for being
with us we appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else